China restricted travel inside Wuhan
yeah couldn't travel to or from Wuhan if
you lived in China not the rest of the
world I remember while the virus was
spreading in China multiple news outlets
reporting in February there was a video
actually showing or appearing to show
people in China being forcibly dragged
from their homes and also quarantined
we haven't been able to independently
verify that video but now in light of
Brett bears and all his exclusive
reporting we need answers if what is
being reported by other people in fact
is true I want to know if that video is
accurate and what did Washington do what
can they now do to hold them accountable
welcome major cities do to protect
themselves from future pandemics here to
explain that and more this is a guy that
knows how to deal with tough times
former New York City Mayor America's
Mayor Rudy Giuliani mr. mayor you know
III tried to bring peace between Cuomo
and the president como goes out again I
need I need and I'm like I tried uh you
know out of mic one he's asked privately
when especially when he told me
yesterday the president delivered from
New York the president picks up a call
how do we open Yankee Stadium I have my
plant what would you do well I I liked
the idea of checking people who go in
maybe you start with half a stadium or a
third of a stadium I opened Broadway
four days after three days after
September 11 they didn't want to open
and I said to them I will I'll protect
everybody that comes in I'll protect all
the I'll protect all the actors the
actresses the band the whole thing the
first night there was maybe a third of
an audience
second night about third of an audience
and then by the next week it was full
again so maybe you start with 20,000
people in the stands spread them out at
least it'll be on television I mean if I
could watch a game on television I would
be it would be like being in heaven for
me I mean I I love watching you Sean and
Laura and but I really would like to see
our Erin judge what I have had the
pleasure of going to a game with you you
have the
best seat in the house right next to the
Yankee dugout good for you and you were
nice enough to share with me once now
here's the thing can we sit like six
feet apart
okay have to say likes I'm better
because I never shut up I talk all the
time so here's the deal if if people
with underlying illness or compromised
immune system they've got to take the
season off I think we agree if everyone
else gets a temperature check and
everybody else wears a mask and you
drink beer through a straw and you're
just to need hot dogs but you can't eat
peanuts or popcorn I think most New
Yorkers have the choices you got to do
that or you don't go I vote to go that's
my vote yeah yeah what we have to do is
I've said this now for about a week we
have to get something started
whatever compromise we have to make to
get it started let's make it so if we
want to play a baseball game with only
20,000 people in the stands maybe maybe
nobody in the stands for a while just
put it on television and then we start
bringing people in but we got to start
going back let's do a Broadway play and
let's stream it live streaming pay to
watch it so the actors come in they can
all be screen but don't usually but he
has if everyone gets a temperature check
and I don't know all the answers I'm
just throwing my little hannity idea
it's the same in new york city if half
the workforce stays home ah now you have
social distancing in every office to get
into an office you get your temperature
check everyone in the office for a while
I know it sucks but you got to wear a
mask I don't wear gloves for a small
period of time that'll all go away after
the after the fall Rob you can open New
York City and you can open Yankee
Stadium am I wrong
no you're not wrong and the plan should
be incremental opening it's like it's
like it builds on itself I watched this
with September 11 first two or three
nights nobody showed up
nothing happened and then people showed
up I'll go with you the first year by
the third so the first game there might
be twenty as I said ten thousand twenty
thousand people all over you or you'll
be lighted as always
I won't be talking the homie lucky
because nobody hear me you'll be six
you'll be six seats away right you get
some peace I never shut up
my married oh but that's not the point
the point that you're making that I'm
making is we've got to start removing
things get the day started
maybe eat maybe even in a small way
just get him started a couple of
Broadway plays well that oh here's my
query well New Yorkers accept that
temperature thing before they go in will
they accept just a short period of time
we need a mask
I would buy it's my buy I'm not I don't
speak for all New York I I will I will I
will I will speak for 90% of them during
this mock in every every every every day
or two I go out of my car and I Drive
around I've been to Brooklyn I've been
to Staten Island I've been to Queens I
was all the way out to Coney Island
I watched New Yorkers they're complying
they are complied they're there they
have been very good let's I mean a
couple of mistakes but very small in the
city of 8.3 million people they have
been very disciplined I'm very proud of
them
can you believe when did the come back
but let's come back and to Blasio's
gotta stop this we're gonna be cleared
down for another six months
a canary did you tell your friend
governor cuomo when he wants more the
president Trump did everything for New
York if we need wants more stone really
gold what he doesn't have to do it
publicly do it privately
work together every time he goes I need
I need I mean it's wrong with me nuts
that's the way I've dealt with his
father he should deal with Trump that
way I pulled them up privately I didn't
embarrass him right exactly and
especially after he delivered and I
never dealt with governor Pataki that
way either
yeah all right mr. mayor privately I'll
go to the first game with you and you
get the benefit and not here to be
chatting I got a mask on and I'm 6 feet
away you're lucky be great perfect for
the umpires can you yell at the umpire
for the man
that's important thing I think I could
do that I'll handle that for everybody
all right Thank You mr. mayor